[Music]
in learning through nature news
submitted by Bart Rapala citizen oh now
you're getting a following is it's a
what a fight between Joe Mallya it's not
right different you know they're like
allies maybe maybe not I don't know yet
Helene II don't like to people yeah it's
really thick you've got thousands like
I'm trying to get his letters Dorothy
only I like to be able to fly yeah like
I'm a Steve Emerald Steve head and I'm
from you think oh haha the cookie
morning genius regarding population zero
and outdoor kindergarten allows kids to
play with saws and cook on open fires
that's also that's really cool I don't
think they should mission title at play
with saws yeah they [ __ ] up could play
with saws and cook outdoor like I just
saw kids going just a can it's an
outdoor can you write them it's a kinder
Kyle I get our most kindergartens like
outdoor like don't they have a big plate
plate plate outside things I play
because I don't never go in a
kindergarten and I just remember playing
outside going inside to sing songs and
sleep and then go back outside and your
teacher was lazy spot what was it
preschool you don't remember eating glue
or anything I'm making crash since I
remember your teachers putting in a lot
of videos right no weren't you learning
the space in like the fourth grade after
that in high school
Oh high school I came from the Los
Angeles Unified School District Reese
cool and I went to kindergarten and I
specifically remember the things that I
learned in kindergarten was we had all
these coloring that line that we had to
follow like diagonal line straight line
circles
it was shapes they would read stories
and we would just be in a you know
sitting down Indian style that's what
they called it back then I remember and
I can't sit indian-style because I'm
pigeon-toed and they would yell at me
because I can't find my legs go the
opposite way
yeah so I sit like my legs go to the sky
oh yeah you're one of those kids but
that took too much space so they were
like you stick Indian style and I
couldn't do it I would cry we we don't
call it Indian cell anymore I don't know
it's not a muscly a non-denominational
style
we called it Foothill style for
elementary school name I do remember
making Thanksgiving things for my mom
where I would get the brown paint and
clear like that and make a turkey
it was 12th grade yeah let me go yes is
that racist now or something I bet it is
probably what a brown dress I'm not
doing turkeys with your hands okay
that's good thank God I'm like [ __ ] no
it's just the vegan food get married oh
yeah so this kindergarten
it's called elves and fairies woodland
Nursery pickle some fairies not taking
mitosis it's located in southern England
cute is good in anyways good I wasn't
even going to see elves and fairies a
little English accent
so they teach kids how to rub two sticks
together make a fire
this was started back in 2007 it's been
fully outdoors for the past 60 years
what their mission statement is a quote
we aim to bring out the creative and
imaginative side of your child and to
inspire a sense of wonder and reverence
for nature through our holistic friendly
approach I hated being semanas okay we
don't believe in teaching them things we
believe in just like talking to them and
all that [ __ ] and mystical [ __ ] right no
they actually do - just put your
astrological sign how does that sound
like to me I'll tell you what they
participated so children as young as two
years old participated singing camp
songs around kindergartner two years old
as kindergarten they're just camping
listen this is an England yeah they
called it a nursery oh and so we don't
call things nurseries here and listen to
the baby's room when I searched the
American equivalent of a nursery I came
up with kindergarten preschool so maybe
preschool maybe a few preschool and then
a preschool and it is kindergarten and
in first grade kindergarten at the
elementary school
preschools like daycare yet like girls
are really gross and then girls are now
there are
I want throw martyrdom still and it's
like oh yeah girls are pretty cool like
that's the order yeah preschool to first
grade third grade fourth grade you start
looking at girls like man you're so cool
I never knew how cool you were like look
at your like shirt it's like making
these bumps I got horny ever since
preschool though they're right how did
you know you get your even one I just
felt it the tingling sensation sure me
too
I've added the Scorpio thing maybe yeah
Scorpios are slow to leave run I saw her
target pretty morning in preschool uh
yeah I remember I was like I'm gonna
catch you there yeah yeah and I didn't
know like it wasn't super sexual but it
was just like like what you guys are
like I'm going to touch either I want to
talk to their teachers okay have fun
oh that's her didn't happen anyway I
would get turned on and stories and in
movies whenever those leave character
got tied up or something I didn't
realize it was a sexual thing but I
would get like really I would pretend to
be that character getting tied up and
like not having control and I would get
like super turned on by that like
they're this partners I'll go for
shadowing so this part and profit goes
west where the bad guy rolls him up and
he's a mouse he gets rolled up into a
burrito and he can't move yeah and I'm
like hold up until burrito and I would
make the other kids that were at the
babysitter's house like okay roll me up
the - a burrito now well I might be
wrong until burritos uber another
meaningful thing you didn't know you're
just cultural yeah Roberto burrito it's
a part of my culture I held it held five
lip like this since I will couldn't even
move and I was like because I want to be
put into a dumpling there's nothing new
about you anyways the kids what else we
do they build shelters they have nature
crafts where they do leaf and bark
rubbing or art and then they also splash
and puddle they climb tree they roll
around the mud Oh God I'd be so [ __ ]
pissed I just bought you those [ __ ]
shampoo boy your father enrolling your
kids yeah I'm some hiking shoes ah and
they all got like old clothes like for
thrift stores and then our kids are
going to look at the homeless kids on
the block you know they're very
connected with nature though
that's bound to happen anyway look
because kids get so freaking dirty man
yeah kids are gets a dirty man they're
never loved my little niece is always
covered in eggs or something hey she
just throws down the floor and residues
compilation you pick it up back yeah go
the dogs always clean it yeah yeah yeah
the dogs are always around her she's
like he's one and a half yeah she just
like walks around you know barely can
keep her own head up
don't like get [ __ ] and just [ __ ]
throw them on the ground the whole day I
usually eat and she get stuff all her
face and then when she's done she just
throws it all that's great and you just
had a restaurant and then you'll be
sitting here and like this is your phone
and she'll just be like yeah dude it
doesn't open like a cat yeah exactly
cats are asking cats reduced to and they
look at you and they're like you know
what but you don't need it okay no no no
no no [ __ ] all your [ __ ] what the skew
my cat so here's some kids how cute
I think big top their own money
description that's pretty awesome that
is awesome
yeah I never done stuff mutters no I
would like to do one I do Spartan races
I've never tried one whatever it sounds
fun yeah they also learn math and things
like that when they collect twigs that
they sign and they were teaching about
them yeah that's really cool
I'm gonna do this scarecrow kid jumping
off boxes oh I thought he was trying to
be a scarecrow he's like on the bus he's
doing the karate kid no he's gonna
cranking Danny this is so cool really
cool I love that he was covered in mud
as adorable yeah all of this is much but
you know what's funny though it's like
this is normal childhood to me so why'd
you have to pay and go to a special
school just for a normal childhood
basically paying people to babysit your
kids
yeah and they're learning in a fun but
see I feel like if you were going to
phone detox you know do you talk
digitally it's like this would be the
kind of place you would want to go to
like
like somewhere where it's fun and you're
like connected in nature not like where
you're in a class studying rules of not
being on your phone yeah let me climb a
tree for three hours roll around the mud
the other night we were with friends and
we all just played that game mafia yeah
oh yeah we know that game and we were
playing that and I was like so much more
fun to being on my phone look it had
that thought look is so like can you
keep it on the table I'm on [ __ ] too
much so crazy well I think that's what
it is like our brains crave stimulation
like figuring [ __ ] out and like you know
looking up stuff and learning and stuff
but since it's not being used for that
we look for on our phone and fake
learning and fake figuring things out
yes that's true
we're also bored enough there's not much
to do you're not the hunt anymore you go
to the grocery store to hunter-gather
like so we're wired to do that and then
we're like don't have an outlet so we
just go to our phone and mistake yeah
think you're [ __ ] a spirit-filled
says who walked through the news and
[ __ ] like that yeah I'm planning on
having kids yeah have you thought about
what kind of school you want to put them
in um
well probably public school well a high
school and then maybe private for high
school unless we're in a good school
district I'm like that something is or
six is pretty much the same wherever you
go like it's not like super crazy
different but then after why it is
because he is a product of that's true
and you said that you learn States in
high school that pretty much guarantee I
mean like what did you learn elementary
school then that's gay man Dan barber
had better schools I guess because it
was a Blue Ribbon School that I was a
public school but it was California
Distinguished
schools and stuff so I don't really know
what the standard school is here in LA
but I've heard it's bad I went to that
it's pretty bad
somebody's gotta go in there and clean
those schools up I think it's going to
be me okay kids listen up
alright you got a new teacher I did kick
my hands in five minutes you do look
like a son to do teaching
do I have that look and imagine me as
layers on layers and they got your
letter base whether it was a tie
underneath with that Mister Rogers shirt
just like this yes that is like the cool
stuff but if you have that Mister Rogers
thing it's like a real fictional
officials yeah I'd like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm not listening on this guy
I don't want you to write your name on
the board but make it a different name
and just don't even yeah well my name is
green with an e right so I could be like
mr. Greenwich Oh
oh my god that's what I'm gonna do you
do Community Schools I know what I'm
gonna do in life when I have a [ __ ] ton
of money and I just don't give a [ __ ]
I'm going to go into schools from areas
that I went to school and then I'm just
gonna walk in a class and be like look
how many of you guys want to go to jail
and get butt-fucked and then you're
gonna hit none right no cuz I could
murder all them I'm gonna go I will go
to school at the gun ha ha you can't do
that to me
I'll have crack I'll throw at them in
exactly the ones that want crack though
just like faster then the ones that want
to talk [ __ ] the you know like I'll have
there oh geez on speed dial so I'll be
like hey what you said what okay hold on
Trey hey talk to your little [ __ ]
juster and then yeah I'll do that
I'll have everything covered and I'll go
to school with a gun and a bat and brass
knob and plug it and vlog it yeah and
I'm going to walk in there and I'll just
say check this out how many of you guys
want to get buff [ __ ] when you grow up
it sounds like you're both the buster
but but look really nice in ten years
I'm watching TV CBS news comes on it's
like a youtuber choice outside it's like
lower third it's like the picture of an
aerial shot of the school it's like
youtuber invade school with the knife
start yelling do you want to get Muslim
starts throwing crack at kids
a armed with several weapon if you guys
don't want to get bump on then listen to
me there's two choices in life you
either make a million dollars and you
change or you're gonna get buff up in
jail what do you want that's the reality
right it still sounds like a threat from
you well I'm not going to be the one
that's going to do it is a million
dollars or you get butt-fucked right now
Yeah right it's got to be scared
straight because it's like hey the
longer you take to make a decision boy
you're going to get buff ugh hey guys
thanks for watching that last episode if
you haven't already make sure to hit
that subscribe button because we upload
videos every single day for you guys now
to watch more videos check them out up
here
[Music]